former secretary of state hillary
clinton says the overturning of roe v
wade should be a wake-up call for
americans we spoke with her yesterday in
the studio this was her first on-camera
interview about the supreme court's
monumental ruling the decision triggered
laws to prevent women in at least seven
states seven from getting legal
abortions now clinton was here yesterday
with her co-author to discuss her novel
state of terror is co it is co-published
by simon schuster which is a division of
our corporate owner that's paramount
global she told us that this is a risky
time for american democracy
last week the roe v wade decision was
made
and even though we had gotten a heads up
many people thought it was unthinkable a
lot of people are still processing
depending on your point of view what did
you think when you heard it
well i was not surprised because i think
that was the goal of packing the court
with justices who were on the record for
many years of being against women's
constitutional rights to
make decisions about our own bodies
i was
deeply
sorry that it actually happened but now
that it has happened
i think everybody understands that
this is not necessarily the only effort
that we're going to see this court
undertake to turn back the clock
on civil rights
and gay rights and women's rights beyond
abortion
this is going to i hope wake up a lot of
americans i don't care what political
party or religion you are the question
is who decides
is the government going to be in your
bedroom is the government going to be
making these decisions we are only at
the beginning of this terrible travesty
that this court has uh inflicted on us
and what do you say to the supporters
though who say listen we are protecting
the rights of unborn children
they have rights too what do you say to
that you know it seems to be the core
argument i i say that you know that is
predominantly
a belief rooted in religion which i
respect
and that's why
in a pluralistic democracy like ours
the
court in roe v wade said
the government is not going to make this
decision
if it is your personal belief based on
whatever that there is no legitimate
basis for abortion even if you're in the
hospital and you're bleeding out
even if you're told that you have cancer
and chemotherapy is necessary and
therefore an abortion is necessary no
matter what you get to make that
decision i might not agree with it but
you get to make that decision but you
and those who support your particular
point of view cannot dictate that
decision to every other woman and you
know for many years the abortion rate
was going down
um we were seeing uh i think greater
responsibility especially with the use
of contraception
so what is it there what is their
ultimate uh goal here if they begin to
chip away at all of these rights it
truly is to
erase the progress that women have made
from the last 150 years you know a
couple of the senators have said that
they were misled by the justices
does this does this say to you that we
need to change the confirmation hearing
process
well
i think they were uh misled
uh in part uh
because they wanted to be misled
they had i think they knew that this was
good they either knew or they were blind
to what the history of the people before
them anyone who is surprised by this
is not paying attention
uh so
these people were selected for this
purpose
and it was a 50-year campaign and you've
got to give the other side
you know lots of points for their
relentlessness their
total commitment to getting what they
want done regardless of who's hurt by it
and regardless of who's stripped of
rights is this the time for the
democrats to take on the filibuster do
you think well i've i've been saying for
quite some time i think the filibuster
is it should be eliminated at the very
least for constitutional questions like
voting rights like a woman's
you know constitutional rights to make
decisions about her own body so if you
can't lift it completely lift it for
those two things that have huge
consequences for our country and last
question you're a former first lady
former secretary of state former senator
do you miss the day-to-day of politics
is there any scenario in your brain you
would think i want to get back in no but
i i miss it
i miss it there's no scenario in 2024
even remotely consider
you know i i can't imagine it i really
can't i but what i don't know well but
what i can't imagine is staying as
active and outspoken as i can because i
think
i i think our country is really on the
precipice scale i think that
we are looking at not only the erosion
of these rights the throwing the door
open to
unfettered unregulated gun
access but we're also looking at
dismantling the federal government how
it protects our air and our water and
everything else that goes through our
democracies at state we're looking at
the january 6 hearings i do you think
the democracy is at stake we sit here
today i do i will anything come of these
hearings people say some say it's a
waste of time i i think these hearings
have been
uh
incredibly powerful
i understand a lot of people pay no
attention but history pays attention
i hope the justice department is paying
attention
i hope in these midterm elections uh
candidates and the democratic party uh
pay attention
because you cannot let those who
attacked our capital and those who urge
them
on to do so
act with impunity that's what happens in
dictatorships and authoritarian regimes
so i think it's important that people
recognize if there were ever a time to
vote and to vote literally for your
rights and our future it's this midterm
yeah i mean you know she had she had a
lot to say she was really very candid
and very open and i like what she said
that history pays attention right
because you know people can say no one's
paying attention to these hearings but
the first hearing 20 million people
watch people are tuning in people want
to know exactly what happened so we will
see today is going to be a very big day
i'm so glad she ended with reference to
voting in this country because when it
comes to democracies our participation
rate is abysmal relative to other
countries around the world and still
people complain though people complain
80 million people don't vote and when
you see hillary clinton on television
what i think about is all the what-ifs
from 2016 what could have been different
it was a small number of people that
swung the election she won the popular
vote if people had gone to the polls
three supreme court justices that had
been appointed by donald trump might
have been appointed by her we don't have
this decision today right about that yes
she's spot on she said we're turning
back the clock